Super Bowl 100 is more than just about
to game of football the Super Bowl is
about our culture what is life gonna
look like 50 years from here
DNA information is a brand new area that
could be providing this new edge to make
you the best that you can be with active
RFID technology we know everything about
what's happening on the field of play in
real time we'll have brand new
technologies that we can't even imagine
right now if we look hard enough we can
find genetic variants that protect
people from injury this project is about
imagination what's the crazy new idea
that we're gonna look back and say oh
yeah that was the thing that we really
changed the game the NFL for example
might be quite interested in what we
left
if you think about sports is an
experiment the first thing you have to
do is collect the data for that
experiment
I can't improve something I can't even
generate a hypothesis if I don't have
data to back that up
I'm guessing rather than being a
scientist about it we went to visit a
company called zebra technologies which
has a center based in San Jose food
motion works for the last several years
zebra has been working with the NFL to
track players very much in the same way
as companies track the inventors we're
in the business of bringing active RFID
technology to that NFL so we track every
player during every game and all their
movements we put two tags on the
shoulders of every player and we track
all those movements through receivers
that are around the stadium 25 times a
second
it's funny cuz we thought it would be
used for coaching in schematics that it
would be all about matchups but it's not
it's all about wellness at the team
level it's really fascinating
the NFL is collecting all of this data
on the players running around how fast
they run where they run exactly what
routes that they're running and they can
use that to understand precisely what
the loads the players have actually put
on their bodies is teams have been using
that information to affect their
training to keep their players fitter
and healthier for longer so p3 in Santa
Barbara what they do is they look at the
biomechanics of an athlete a lot of the
player tracking it's going on right now
it's helping us get a better
understanding of what a player's demands
are during a game if you understand the
loads that a player is incurring and
then you'll also understand how the
players system deals with these external
loads which is our world then you have
the two principal variables in
predicting injury risk the average
career span of a NFL running back is
about three years that's a short time
for professionally to have a career and
it speaks the fact that we're just
learning how to really specialize really
really individualize and really
bulletproof these athletes the idea that
a lineman is going to train the same way
as a running back as the same way as a
wide receiver that's already starting to
go away but it's going to be pushed so
much further really treating each
athlete as specifically as possible our
model and really the purpose for our
effort in this field is to objectify
these unique systems that separate
athletes it's gonna be about specifying
programming its performance data its
injury risk data it's all about the
depth this athletes very very individual
needs and his individual risks these
athletes that have a chance to have
professional careers they're rare
resources it's a big investment so the
team's want this data they're just
figuring out what to do with it right
now though this is a new brave world for
these guys
the Tigers were bracing for the worst
news it appears they have received the
worst news so far this season the Green
Bay Packers have lost Jolly Nelson their
star wide receiver with an ACL tear and
Tony Romo the quarterback of the Cowboys
has been out with a broken collarbone
those seem like injuries that maybe we
can't predict but actually maybe we can
I'm very interested in trying to find
out how to use DNA information to help
athletes stop their injuries
genetically precision is is key the way
a lot of athletes train is imprecise
one-size-fits-all one-size-fits-all
model not every athlete is the same as
we know every athlete is an individual
and so oh maybe maybe were more similar
than they're probably more so but I
think precision is is very important and
I think in ten years or beyond what we
can do is take genetic information and
personalized training for athletes with
the goal of optimization can we optimize
everything that an athletes doing for
their specific body so I'm talking to
guard for the New Orleans Saints I'm
telling him about injury risk and I said
oh by the way looks like you have a
couple of risk alleles for Achilles
tendinopathy and he just lit up you said
what what's that if you can look at gene
variants in different people and see how
they can build collagen which is the
main structural protein in ligaments and
maybe you can predict which people have
weaker ligaments which people have
stronger ligaments you know if a tendon
has one single nucleotide polymorphism
versus another then it's going to be
more likely to break
this is a simple example with just the
beginning of the type of information we
have that NFL player should really
clamor to know
it's not gonna take 50 years to get to
the point where athletes go out get
their DNA analyzed and then take it to
their trainers to use it to understand
really how they can make himself better
by looking at those gene variants what
you can do with the technology now
that's crazy the Human Genome Project
was targeted for 3 billion dollars it
took 10 years involved 10 different
countries
it's equals one genome and that was only
10 or 15 years ago and then today we can
sequence a human genome for under $1,000
and that's that's a million fold change
in cost now we can see was a human
genome for less money that cost for an
MRI and when you think about that and
how that might impact medicine that's
very transformative so maybe if we look
hard enough we do these studies we come
together we collaborate we can find
genetic variants that protect people
from injury that protect people from
concussion and that we can start to
think about how we can use those
insights to actually keep athletes safer
in terms of where we can go in 50 years
time when we look at DNA analysis the
sky has to be the limit it will be
standard not just for athletes but for
every single one of us to have knowledge
of what I DNA is know what our injury
susceptibility is know what our illness
accessibility is here's the thing you
don't want to leave anything to chance
the athlete a future this is just going
to be second nature to him this is just
a part of the world professional
football players realize that when they
step on the field it's like stepping in
the ring you know it's a dangerous
environment and the more bulletproof
they can become before they step in the
ring before they go gladiator then the
best chance they have to survive do you
have any questions okay when we can
finally get to the place that we're
treating each individual athlete truly
as an individual and really tailoring
everything about their lives from their
training program to their nutrition and
when everything can be focused exactly
on that one person I think we have a lot
of potential to unlock in athletes